the jurgen experience i was
i was talking last night like i don't
know much about my
the different the the level of education
women have about their reproductive
organs
versus men oh yeah like my
my balls i know about my balls i know
that the medical term is testicles
that's about it don't go hot if you get
them hot
yeah again that's like that's like a
child
you know what i mean like it and you
only know that from like oh cause i got
him hot one time right
but i don't know how seaman
gets to the i don't know the name of the
two i don't know
anything and that's my body
right women know tons of they know
fallopian tubes
vulva cervix like everything um
yeah guys know prostate cancer
my [ __ ] oh yeah okay
and not curious i mean like not like
curious in a way of like ah let's just
hope
just hope for those it's none of my
business plus to get checked out you
have to have a finger in your ass and
everybody puts that off yeah now
meanwhile women do that once a year
constantly they're always getting jabbed
at and swabbed swabbed
yeah they get the pap smear a smear
smears in the title yeah
jesus just every imagine if you
needed people to come inside you you
need them to not just
not just exchange bodily fluids by
kissing
no they have to squirt something in you
to make people
yeah except this odd they're poisonous
little dirty dna
they're dirty little [ __ ]
infected it's awfully gross
when you if you get like 10 feet away
from it you're like jesus yeah
what they're doing but while you're in
the moment it seems like it's the most
logical you got to do it can't not do it
yeah
did you uh speaking of that uh did you
see the thing about gerard
no that i don't if you want to bring it
up but he basically
came out a little on hbo
came out a little came out a little to
his mom said i've had
uh sexual experiences with men uh oh
um and uh it's uh it's just like all
right
was she cool with it yeah she was cool
it yeah
that's the thing when i people are like
what do you think i'm like i don't
that sexual preference at this point to
me is about as interesting as like
your workout origin like i just don't
care like what are you doing there you
go cool you know what i care about are
you funny
are you funny and are you cool yeah and
and like do we have [ __ ] to talk about
right great yeah i don't i couldn't care
less
who's what type of hand you like jerking
you know what i mean like
i think what kind of mouth with some
guys like tim dillon i think it's an
advantage with his act that he's gay
yes he's so ridiculous and over the top
and he's just like big fat
gay guy yeah but he doesn't really talk
does he talk about it
he'll talk about it sometimes yeah but i
mean it's not a big deal to him he
treats it the way a guy treats his
sexuality like you don't have to go
blaring through the streets that you're
straight all the time right you are i
usually assume you're really not
right like there's no yeah they're
straight you're straight
yeah if you're not no one [ __ ] cares
the comedy community
literally no one cares yeah it doesn't
it makes no difference the only thing
that bums me out is when guys hide it
it's like come on does it bum you out
for them or
for them yeah it really bumps but having
said that
i get it i get it like i it's a real
bummer it's sad we know a few guys that
are
in the closet it's you just feel bad for
them like exactly like
yeah man i hope it's not unbearable
right you know what i mean like
like i i get while you're while you're
in the closet i get why actors in the
closet like
especially male actors like because it
doesn't serve them
to come out it's not gonna it's not
gonna help them i think it's the worst
thing for them
in terms of like getting roles as a
heterosexual
if you're a known homosexual you almost
can't get
roles as a heterosexual yeah like i
remember there was some
who was uh what is that guy's name neil
patrick harris he was in something
where he played like this arrogant guy
who likes girls
he was in uh
how i met your mother yeah and that
worked he also played a straight guy in
uh gone girl pretty well
yeah was that before or it was after
they've both been after
really and i was all because i said i
was surprised that that's what he played
but like
certain people they just i don't know he
might be the only guy
i agree that like he came out and
it's not then he's he you buy it somehow
as a romantic lead you think that it's
like it
cancels that out like if tom cruise
decided to come out if tom cruise is gay
and he decided to come out
like that would be a real problem you
know what i was talking to somebody
about this the other day you know would
be a hilarious movie idea
uh gay couple tom cruise and
uh john travolta john travolta gets
kidnapped
and gay tom cruise has to save his gay
husband
john travolta and but other than that
it's a real action movie
wow it's just gay i like it wouldn't
that be [ __ ] cool
like just a straight get if anyone out
there is a screenwriter that
have at it because i'm never going to
write it would that fly would people
enjoy that like if it was really good
like john wick's style
i think it would i really think it would
if it was if the guy just
kick it's not like gay guys are like a
feet in the face i know plenty of
like rough gay guys that'll whoop your
ass bro
bears bro they got they got their own
crowd
that's how [ __ ] bad these guys are uh
yeah
really it would be [ __ ] so cool like
you're just gonna yeah because that's
how i feel with someone like draw coming
out i'm like
i don't care okay i know it's never come
up we've
we've been good friends for a decade
just never came up
yeah like it just he didn't seem that
interested in women but i don't also
don't think he's not interested he's
just maybe there's definitely a spectrum
right and some people are just
oh yeah and that's fine too yeah yeah
i'm also not
met like if i were on the spectrum i
think i would absolutely do it
yeah i'm just not on the spectrum like i
but in terms of opportunity
there's a lot of nights a year joe oh
yeah there's 365 nights a year oh yeah
you could
you're not going to do the dick [ __ ]
dick [ __ ] yeah go back and you go back
anymore same thing split it up
dahmer had the best joke about that he
goes he goes i
he goes this is how little i give a [ __ ]
he goes i
wish i was gay just so i could come out
yeah because i wish
i wish i had a secret like that
yeah because that's how little i give a
[ __ ] it's so true
it's like his joke about i'm gaining
weight for a movie i don't know what the
movie is yet but
it's a [ __ ] great joke um
yeah but the gay action movie would be
fantastic i like it
i do too within a year or two people
would be definitely ready for it
i if it were a legit good action movie
yeah i think they'd be if it were tom
hardy even if maybe if they were both
one of them was straight and one was tom
hardy and
he just plays gay and mm-hmm and like
he's it's it's taken
right but it doesn't have to be two gay
guys could be even crazier two straight
guys
who have to make out yeah they could be
played by straight guys
absolutely then we're right now we're
talking now we're really talking now
you're talking
and now you're talking commitment
because i was thinking about
do women if tom cruise was gay right uh
and he just came out and there's a movie
where he has to save his wife
would women not believe it do you know
what i mean like yes like so
if you come out so it's like all right
so now in the next mission impossible
they just kidnap his husband yeah well
for sure you could do that with lesbians
if you had two hot lesbians uh yeah of
course 100
yeah no there's zero issues that would
be no problem
uh there'd be no resistance and that's
the difference between
a lesbian actress they can go a woman
who's a lesbian
you know why i believe gay straight
because
there's a big portion of men who never
truly believe a lesbian
i have a bit about it yeah i had a bit
about from one of my old specials
it's like we believe that you believe
you're a lesbian
yeah but uh you just ain't got a piece
of this sweet dick yet
you never spent a saturday with me at uh
[ __ ] applebee's i hit you with an
applebee's in the
bar corner bar forget it the panty
dropper tequila shots what do you got uh
brokeback mountain yeah it wasn't really
an action though
for sure that both of those guys are not
gay we do not
we see us i mean
jake gyllenhaal's straight and you say
so heath ledger but you saw that movie
house i mean come on man you saw he you
believed it
no one's that good at acting definitely
crazy there's no way he could play crazy
that guy's definitely gay trust me i
know
things i've seen many movies
and understand them i know when
someone's acting
and someone's just gay a [ __ ] kid but
that was easy for him
yeah no it would be that but running
around yeah that could happen
that could i think that could happen i
think we're on the verge of that
i would enjoy it i'm happy for it
because
then people stop getting free passes
where you're goofy but you're gay so we
let you slide with right silly behavior
like no no no no no i want equality i
want you
me to be able to call you a dunce and
not have to worry about being homophobic
and no one hears gay dunce right when
you say it you're just gonna use this
guy's a [ __ ] dummy you're like hey
hey hey hey
yeah god you're homophobic yeah oh my
god
[Applause]